avoir la main verte c'est en quelque
sorte posséder un don pour soigner les
plantes mais pour les horticulteurs cela
ne suffit pas toujours pour bien
entretenir les massifs de fleurs ou les
plantes d'appartement un minimum de
connaissances et de techniques leur
paraît nécessaire
c'est pour cela que les responsables du
jardin botanique du montet à nancy en
mis en place cet été des cours et des
conférences pour gratuit assuré par des
professionnels destinées à démythifier
l'entretien des plantes vertes aux yeux
des amateurs qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à visiter les richesses du
jardin botanique ce magnifique jardin et
ont fait un conservatoire vivant du
monde végétal créée en 1974 le jardin
botanique du montet constitué à l'époque
la seule création de ce type en france
depuis 50 ans une création intervenue
grâce à une association entre le
district de l'agglomération nancéenne l
université les objectifs sont bien sûr
scientifiques mais aussi culturel et
éducatif
le jardin botanique du monte et s'étend
actuellement sur 25 hectares il offre
une collection pleine sert au fond plus
de 3000 espèces des espèces répertoriées
et les visiteurs grâce aux indications
portées sur des pancartes de
différencier les plantes des collections
médicinales historiques ou en emmental
toujours en pleine évolution le jardin
bretelle du monte à des projets pour 1 3
le conservatoire et jardin botanique ne
sont pas tout à fait terminée tout au
mal à la maison mère le jardin botanique
du montet et actuellement nous terminons
une grande serre palmarium qui sera
destiné à mettre des palmiers c'est vrai
mais surtout des plantes menacées des
territoires et départements d'outre-mer
nous travaillons aussi à installer à
l'île de la réunion un conservatoire de
botanique tropicale
ce qui est tout à fait dans notre
mission au sujet des plantes menacées le
palmarium viendra s'ajouter aux quatre
serres déjà existante des serres qui
regroupe plus de 6000 espèces parmi les
plus impressionnantes pour le public
les célèbres victoria legia c'est énorme
faille ressemblant des plateaux à tarte
au diamètre impressionnant et qui
s'étale dans une mare les graines de
toutes les plantes cultivées en pleine
terre en serre sont recueillis un
catalogue skira plus de 900 exemplaires
les propose dans le monde entier
le jardin botanique du monstre est
remplie ici son rôle de préservation
mais il n'oublie jamais le côté éducatif
et pour cela ils multiplient les
manifestations permettant au public de
mieux connaître les plans ainsi les
cours de jardinage d'été
le conservatoire et jardin botanique ont
un comment dirais-je un département
culturel et pédagogique c'est un grand
musée vivant des plantes et nous avons
besoin de contact permanent avec le
public soit par ses cours par des
causeries par les expositions et là nous
avons un exemple parfait par des visites
commentées et nous essayons de 2,2
passes et le loup goût du monde végétal
la connaissance du monde végétal à
l'ensemble et à tout public
les cours de jardinage sont organisées
conjointement avec l'office de tourisme
et le service des espaces verts de nancy
ils sont gratuits et cette année leur
thème principal sera l'arrêt lafleur le
premier cours portaient sur les plantes
d'appartement et pour les spécialistes
il s'agissait de donner au public des
tuyaux pour cultiver leurs plantes
10 min intéresser plus spécialement
qu'avant j'aime les plats les plantes
d'appartement plantes d'appartement et
plantes de jardin et l'avancement
un petit jardinet parfois c'est comme
j'espère aussi connaître un peu et
améliorer les massifs que je suis j'ai
voulu voir en fait que ces données aient
fait par un conférencier ça m'a semblé
plus apte à répondre à mes désirs mieux
que dans des livres s'approfondit les
connaissances dérive parce que c'est
orale ce que j'ai pas pu voir dans un
livre je peux le demander à quelqu'un
qui m'expliquera je profite du fait
qu'ils aient des cours ici pour la 2d
peu plus et les plantes ça vous
intéresse
ah oui beaucoup j'ai envie de faire la
passe temps je suis utile
de devenir un peu sur l'horticulture
j'adore la nature et les plantes
d'appartement aussi j'en ai beaucoup à
la maison et vous savez bien vous en
occuper on lui bien sûr
alors ce court ça vous apporte quoi on
fait toujours de nouvelles données tout
le temps très bien de le voir comment ça
se fait pratiquement
il a besoin de toucher donc pas une
analyse aussi voir ça de se refermer